The building blocks of urbanism are
things that started many, many tens of
thousands of years ago. One of them in
particular is language: the possibility
of speaking, not only to communicate
information, but also to think about
things that are not there, like the past and the future—both of
which are entirely imaginary constructs,
but for which we have the language to be
able to envision something that is not
there. Even more important is the
opportunity to put in a conditional
tense, not just a past, present, and a
future, but a 'what if?' 'If we build it,
they will come.' That kind of planning is
something that was absolutely essential, not only to our long human survival, but to
the eventual possibility of living in
larger and larger configurations of
strangers. Another thing that humans are
very good about is dealing with objects.
We're the only species that has stuff,
and certainly has so much stuff. And we
have been trying to invent new things
since the very beginning. The first
artifacts of any detailed aesthetic
consequence were from about a million
and a half years ago. And those artifacts
were made in quantities that suggested
that mere utility was not enough as part
of the human composition of making the
world around them, of making tools, for
example. The first artifacts were things
called hand axes. And they look a little
bit like the two palms of your hand put
together. And we'd have a hard time
making one even today with our
sophisticated technical skills, because
it requires a certain amount of
imagination to turn a stone over and
over again and manufacture them without
hurting yourself. And the amount of work
that goes into these objects is far
beyond what would be required to make a
useful sharp-edged tool.
In fact, there's been some interesting
thought about the way that people
manufactured those hand axes, not only to
be something useful, but to be a kind of
social calling card. 'Hey baby. Look at my
hand axe.' Another thing that's really
important for humans, and that has been
part of our makeup for a long time, has
been migration. So more than a million
years ago, our ancestors walked out of
Africa and into every corner of the old
world. That process of walking is still
there. Migration is not a new phenomenon;
it's a human phenomenon. And the last
thing that humans do that became a
precursor for the kinds of things we
needed to become urban is the
development of architecture, of not just
accepting the world as it is, of being
able to find a shelter under a tree or
in a cave, but to actually make
structures that suit people, not only for
shelter but also as a kind of social
calling card, as a way of putting
together a household and making it
visible to the rest of the people around.
So those are the things that are the  building blocks of what it took
to be able to be urban. But many of those
things were done for tens of thousands
of years before people actually became
an urban species. And the first move
towards getting people into larger and
larger groups was probably something
that was a ritual impetus. The idea of
coming together and gathering with a
bunch of strangers with something that
is evident in the earliest physical
ritual structures that we have in the
world today. So you see here Stonehenge,
which of course is very familiar to us,
and very picturesque and evocative. And
then you also have Gobekli Tepe, which is
probably the world's earliest ritual
structure in Turkey. Made by
hunter-gatherers who were coming
together and constructing
upright stone circles over and over
again to be able to make a place for
people to come together and have a
ritual. And we know archaeologically that
these are places where people came
repeatedly over and over again. They came,
they had celebrations, they had fires,
they did cooking, they interred their
dead. And all of that was very exciting,
including probably also people coming
along with trinkets to sell, or also, you
know, people coming along for a little
romance. Down in the village
where there were only 50 or 60 people at
any given time, marriage prospects were
probably rather limited. So the idea of
going to a ritual event with
something like a festival atmosphere, so
that you could have a little shopping, a
little ritual, a little romance, all at
the same time. But there was a
catch about these ritual centers. And
that is, that after you were done with
the ritual, you were supposed to go home.
So when we think about places like
Stonehenge, we think about places like
Gobekli Tepe, there are still no cities
anywhere near them. So it took something
more in order to be able to get people
to live in a place that was kind of like
a permanent festival atmosphere. And once
that started, once you had a kind of
economy of people living together, of all
kinds of new opportunities for romance,
for education, for medical care—that's
when the first cities got going.